[Musik]
kaum etwas in deutschland ist so
erfolgreich wie die automobilindustrie
wichtigste arbeitgeber größter
steuerzahler exportweltmeister made in
germany doch plötzlich läuft nicht mehr
alles rund
alle welt fragt sich sind die denn
verrückt geworden
made in germany das kann doch nicht sein
dass der bürger hier im regen steht und
dann sein neues auto kaufen sollte
30.000 also wo stehen wir eigentlich
hier kann ja nicht jeder jede alle zwei
jahre ein auto kaufen ach was für ein
traum für die autohersteller
jeder bürger alle zwei jahre ein neues
auto was für ein geschäft
[Musik]
aber eigentlich müssten sie erst mal
jene dieselautos nachrüsten die sie bis
vor kurzem noch verkauft haben die aber
zu viel stickstoff dioxid ausstoßen
auch das macht ihr viele verrückt
[Applaus]
schon schließen sich husten anwohner
stark befahrener straßen zusammen und
ein gericht nach dem anderen verhängt
fahrverbote davon sind sehr viele
autofahrer betroffen
200.000 allein in berlin 100.000 in köln
und und und schon ab nächstem jahr
dürfen sie viele strecken nicht mehr
fahren
völlig ungeklärt wer und wie soll
kontrolliert werden so viele polizisten
gibt es gar nicht in deutschland eine
automatische kennzeichenerfassung will
aber auch keiner
und wie verlässlich sind eigentlich die
messdaten in der einen stadt wird direkt
neben der straße gemessen in der
nächsten stadt zehn meter entfernt in
der einen stadt messen sie in vier meter
höhe in der anderen im boden mehr
dieses video wurde schon drei millionen
mal geklickt
von meinem stinker bevor ich mich schon
wieder nur free youtube nicht hassen
doch ich gebe mein flitzer nicht zurück
zurückgeben liegt gerade voll im trend
auf deutschlands schrottplätzen ist kaum
noch platz die autohersteller zahlen für
die verschrottung alter diesel prämien
bis zu 5000 euro
wenn sich der fahrer ein neues auto
kauft hast du ganz schön weh weil so ein
fahrzeug der hat 47 tausend kilometer
runter er ist so sauber natürlich der
könnte noch einige jahre auf der straße
vor am 1
es sind
[Applaus]